this is a production of Cornell
University all right thanks Sarah as she
said my name is Jenna Hershberger I'm a
second year grad student in my course
lab and today I'll be talking about one
of several projects that I'm working on
and this one's called an Android
application for near-infrared
spectroscopy based you know typing of
Kesava quality traits so this project is
part of a larger Fino Apps project
that's funded by NSF
and this project is led by Mike Gore as
well as Jesse Poland who is here a few
weeks ago so the main problem that the
pheno apps project is looking to address
is this one typically when reading
programs take notes it's by hand on
paper you get bookshelves that look like
this this is an actual photo from ITA of
their breeding data also lovingly known
as old-school cassava base so you know
apps integrate data collection with the
actual new cassava base out of BTI and
that's one way that we are increasing
the efficiency with which breeding
programs can take phenotypic data but
beyond this Fino apps also have the
possibility of collecting data that's
not possible by hand such as spectral
data and image data so one of the other
important parts of the pheno apps
project is workshops so deployment of
the apps and this these are pictures
from a workshop that we held at iit a in
march and so we train breeders on how to
use the apps and ask for feedback on the
apps that are being used and then
potential apps that could be developed
in the future so we asked the breeders
what traits are you working on that
could use a more efficient tool and we
got a lot of responses so one of them
that we hadn't really put too much
thought into before is dry matter
content in cassava so dry matter content
is really important to cassava breeders
to farmers and to
consumers cassava roots are the
harvested part of the plant they're
mostly starch in the dry matter is what
is actually cared about so the dry
matter is a large component of yield
it's used as a proxy for eating quality
and it's really important for farmers
which factors into then variety adoption
as they want to grow crops that are
actually going to be consumed by Zoomers
and can be used for processing for
eating things like that so the problem
though is cassava dry matter can be
difficult to measure so there are two
main ways that it's normally measured
through the specific gravity method and
the oven method so on the right we have
the specific gravity method as measured
last year in one of Hollis fields Paul
is another lab member of mine so this
method takes you take the roots still in
the field take a subset of them from
your plot weigh them in air and then in
water and use a simple equation to
translate that into dry matter content
the other method is the oven method
which you take your samples back to the
lab you peel your roots you shred them
you measure them before and after they
go through the drying process and that's
how you get dry matter content the there
is though a third way that people have
started using and this is nears or
near-infrared spectroscopy so this is
being used as it's there's a benchtop
spectrometer that's being used to see
out there other organizations as well
that have jumped on board and it's been
proven highly accurate fast and also
yeah it's just very useful so the
problem though is you still have to take
all your samples back to the lab process
them and then put them through the
spectrometer so there's another version
of this where instead of being in the
lab you have a handheld unit and so this
is something that you go out of Jean
Luc's lab is exploring and he has shown
that also that method can have high
accuracy but the problem with these is
the cost is prohibitive so before I go
into that I'm going to talk a little bit
about what yours is
so Neer's is this region of the
electromagnetic spectrum from 700 to
2500 nanometers and the reflectance as
measured by a spectrometer can be
indicative of the chemical composition
of whatever you're measuring so it
changes the reflectance patterns based
on the carbon hydrogen nitrogen hydrogen
and oxygen hydrogen bonds total carbon
carbon and nitrogen so this chart shows
some of the properties that can be
measured by nears and then this is a
screenshot from one of the apps we're
working on that shows some variation
between different routes for these
traits so because the cost is
prohibitive for the NIR spectra
spectroscopy but it's a promising
technology we've been looking into lower
cost options to use nearest in the field
so we found this device it's called scio
it has a smaller range than what's been
used in the past to measure dry matter
content in cassava and so in order to
move forward with this technology I've
been working with Hugo to subset his
data from his handheld years that has
high accuracy and see if this range is
still accurate in predicting dry matter
using his developed models so with that
we've gone we have reduced the accuracy
from 96.7% with holdout cross-validation
to 93.3 but 93.3 is still pretty high
for a tool that is a 200 times reduction
in price so this each unit is about 300
dollars instead of tens of thousands of
dollars so we're looking at something
that is actually feasible for breeders
to be using in their programs and could
be really useful in taking dry matter
data quickly in the field without having
to transport samples and also accurately
so in order to then move forward with
this project Paul
I set up a small pilot experiment
upstairs in the lab here using roots
from Wegmans and that you can see in the
picture on the left here we're just
practicing the protocol for scanning the
roots
the device has a small plastic shield by
the actual spectrometer and that you can
put flesh with the root slice which the
roots are already sliced a phenotype for
a different diseases so handy there you
can just use the slices that are already
cut and scan them so we've worked on the
protocol and now have moved into a pilot
field trial so Paula is currently in
Uganda harvesting her G wast trial for
softness and the roots are already being
phenotyped for specific gravity as well
as these disease traits that require the
slicing of the root so we've hired an
extra team member for her to be able to
scan the roots as part of the
phenotyping process and these same roots
are then being taken first the specific
gravity measurements and we also have
some of them going for the oven method
just to round it all out so this harvest
is taking place starting this week
these pictures are actually from last
year but this is the idea of what will
be happening so and then after we get
the data from this pilot trial we will
then be making some prediction models
I'm looking into using partially squares
regression which will reduce the
dimensionality of the spectral data and
account for the multi collinearity
between wavelengths and then we'll be
doing some cross-validation and then
hopefully some auditioning additional
phenotyping for model improvement with
more more measurements of dry matter and
scans prepared to be able to predict
better and ultimately all this will be
packaged into an app for Android that
will be able to join the rest of the
pheno apps in this suite of apps that
are all free on Google Play for breeders
to use and
with that I would like to thank Paula
and ago especially for their help on my
project as well as my committee Mike
Rebecca and Tim the rest of the gore lab
the pheno ops team and so thanks and
I'll take questions
yeah so with those we really doubt
there's a lot of variation with those
routes we did measure them using a
drying oven and there wasn't a ton of
variation but some of the routes were
actually statistically different from
each other in dry matter so we are
waiting on a research license to be able
to look at the actual spectra to start
our actual model development so we don't
know right now how that's going to look
but we'll see that's why we actually
need a pilot experiment to larger scale
be able to tell
yeah
so yeah so for this tool it has a little
cover on it that you can take off and
then turn the device over put it back in
the cover and you press a button and it
will calibrate for you
so in our protocol we're doing that
between plots it's probably a little bit
overkill but we'd rather have that then
not have it correctly calibrated okay
all right if there are no more questions
let's thank Jenna one more time this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu